they know all films are not going to
work
so they're but they're they're playing
the long game of making multiple films
over the course of a year and that they
know that the winners will pay for the
losers
why is your advice to filmmakers to not
make movies for money well
so it depends on the level of investment
of a film and what you know what my
advice changes film to film for sure and
filmmaker to filmmaker depending on
their goals and what they're doing so
if you want to make if your passion is
to make a film about growing mushrooms
and you want to spend an hour and a half
just watching the mushrooms grow
you know you shouldn't
tell an investor you need 150 000 to
shoot that movie and it'll get on
netflix for sure right
but if you can go out and do it for
your own pocket change and you can do it
on your iphone and then you can put it
in an art museum
okay great that's your passion that you
have found an interesting way to film
those mushrooms right
um
the point there is i guess
that
um if you make something low budget and
because it's your and it's your passion
and everybody knows
the high risk of whatever you're
spending
then great
everybody's going in eyes wide open
but ultimately most films just
monetarily fail
overwhelmingly fail
um
and that's not because of
distributors
being crooked although there's a little
of that in places
it's not because they spend too much
money
advertising or putting in their pockets
or have exorbitant deals it's because
there's
overwhelming amount of content out there
for consumers to consume
and
just no way to monetize every
independent film that everybody makes in
in a way that makes sense vis-a-vis the
budget
um
i i'm in the position of seeing the the
results for
you know intimately of over a thousand
films in 25 years
and overwhelmingly
the
most films fail that's just that's just
the reality of the marketplace if you
look at
not to name names but if you look at a
decent art house distributor
one of the ones that distributes 20 to
25 films a year
and has a prominent
brand
um and well thought of and everybody
wants to be with
if you look at their box office for each
of the films that year there are a
couple that get over a million dollars
and there's about 20
that make 200 to a few thousand dollars
and they've spent money to try to make
those films into something and it just
didn't work
right
so
um
that's why everyone should approach
filmmaking as the business with a huge
amount of caution because it's it's it's
better to put your film in a mutual your
money in a future mod sorry your money
in a mutual fund
right it's not a
film is not a great investment
um
um
and so
you know if you are making a film for in
the two to three million dollar range
there are ways to go about it without
just taking someone's
cash and blowing it that to amortize the
risk
um or to minimize the risk
um
you can shoot in an estate with a tax
credit like to take care of 25 and 30
percent of the budget so narrowing how
much the person has to spend in cash on
the film
there's getting uh involved with a
international sales agent and getting
cast that they can sell the film on
to to pre-sell the film so that you can
take those contracts and cat and get
cash for those from a bank in order to
squeeze down then the amount of equity
you have to spend
so there are ways to
minimize it so that you've let's say
you've made a two million dollar film
and you've now all you need in equity is
25 of the budget
you know you're making a two million
dollar film essentially for
uh half a million dollars
now
hopefully
with the name that you've got
and the quality of the film you made
when you're when it's done
you'll be able to present to the
territories you didn't pre-sell and get
numbers that are bigger than that half a
million but you're still risking that
half million dollars
um if it turns out badly
it's gone
and there's just only so many films a
year that distributors who can pay a
million dollars plus for a film are
gonna buy
um like i said there's like 10 000 films
made a year
and
you know big
you know the biggest distributors that
actually take on indie films only want a
couple of them
um
you know companies you know a little a
little lower down want 20-25 the ones
that are doing you know real theatrical
films here
um they're some that want 10 to 20.
and then there are
there's a you know good number of
i would call kind of mostly all rights
digital distributors who sometimes do
theatrical as well
but most of them aren't paying a lot of
money for films
so
you know when you're looking at the film
as a business you have to realize it's
hardly even a business it's practically
throwing money away
um
and the thing that studios and and
bigger distributors know is that not
they know all films are not going to
work
so they're but they're they're playing
the long game of making multiple films
over the course of a year and that they
know that the winners will pay for the
losers over time as independent
filmmaker one making one movie you're
taking one shot
and
that makes it even a higher risk
so going back to the argument of you
know
[Music]
don't try to make money from the film it
seems like it's an interesting thing in
that
do you make it for the market and try to
try to cash in on it or do you make it
based on something you're really
passionate about but then is it going to
be marketable
yeah that's tough i think you have to
look to the individual and their soul
and what they're about at the end of the
day right and
there are some people that
have is
they have it all
they have
the talent
they have something they're very
passionate about that that is
let's say it's a dramatic story that
isn't a thriller horror or family film
it's not obviously commercial but
they've just really they've written it
well people are responding to on the
page
actors are responding to on the page
financiers are responding on the page
and then it all comes together and it
becomes this great thing
that does well it sells to netflix or
sells to a big company
that can happen but those are very rare
occurrences
um
[Music]
so i think all filmmakers have to kind
of juggle that stuff some people also
inherently have commercial sensibilities
and they grew up
loving spielberg and
and uh
and ron howard and people and who people
who had commercial sensibility and they
tell this kind of instinctively tell
commercial stories
um
there's some people that don't they go
you know they're more uh fellini fans or
truffaut or someone like and that's what
the way they see the world but they you
know
and probably having those influences is
gonna make the way they tell stories a
little different
um and so that has to be kind of brought
to the mix of like how does this
how does this talent
converge with what's commercial i don't
think it's ever really good
you know to
make a movie because well it's the right
genre and we've got the right name
but
the talent the director's okay
and the screenplay is okay right that's
you know okay maybe they'll trade
dollars because they could pre-sell the
movie
and get some money based on the name
and it gets an okay
deal but it's probably just trading
dollars at the end of the day it's
probably not gonna the film's probably
not gonna lift beyond that
i think there you have to take into
consideration kind of everything
um in this business when you're making a
film again depending on the budget again
if you're going out and spending ten
thousand dollars
on your little movie
go crazy right like you're only risking
your own ten thousand dollars
um and there are there are lots of
people doing that and that's that's fine
right as long as you understand that
like you're probably not getting a 100
000
hbo deal
out of that
so cursed are the ones that
want to do a movie on shiitake mushrooms
with organic soil and and but you never
know if it's just the greatest mushrooms
yeah only cursed if they think that
they're
gonna get a netflix deal out of it right
okay if it's so if it's okay that they
make it and show it in an art museum
perfectly legitimate right there's an
audience there there are people that
like avant-garde
interesting
experimental things
but you don't see that stuff on
the major streamers you don't see
you know even
you know ifc magnolia a24 they're not
picking up
you know avant-garde stuff or just even
or weird stuff i mean if you look at
most their slates it's fairly commercial
stuff even though it's
you know you know high brow and has
interesting filmmakers
a lot of them you know you look at genre
you know a lot of love those films are
thrillers and horror films they're just
elevated in some way right a good
portion of them
um none of those guys are doing like you
know 25 dramas
a year
um the market wouldn't bear it for them
it wouldn't work
yeah i don't know why this keeps coming
into my my mind right now but searching
for sugar man which was such an
excellent film i know some people were
critical of it i loved it
but it was able to sort of
transcend i mean it it won an academy
award correct or yeah i think so yeah
yeah and and so here here's a story that
seems kind of unlikely
and it was just so beautifully told and
the the main character was so
fascinating and there are anomalies
right so this is like but you just don't
build a business which is each film is
almost a business at a certain budget
level
right
um
you can't you can't build a business
based on an anomaly right
you have to you should you should look
at genre you should look at cast you
should look at those things depending on
what your budget level is
um there's certain budget levels you
can't afford cast right you can't afford
names
that will work on your film
um
you know unless your
uncle is tom cruise you know like then
then you know you're you're most likely
not casting someone that that helps prop
up the movie
so um
i think
you have to factor in cast and genre in
your budget
um you know in addition
something i don't think enough people do
is
vet their screenplay you know
with
get a hundred people to read it you know
get script services to read it get
feedback
um
there's so many so many films that i
have to turn down that i think wow is
really well shot and
and the acting's competent
but there's just no story here or
there's just not enough of the story we
didn't get the story fast enough you
know there's certain kind of rules of
screenwriting you know you kind of have
to follow
in order to make a you know a commercial
movie